un peu dun peu ditatif, ubitatit
de la gade la gahe Gustauche Gu.
Mais un Mais un iomphe? triomph.
Avec pluAvec plude 40 % s de 40,
il arrivil arrivlargemene largee
et s'attet s'attd à devend à der
présidenprésidende la gat de lae
de la Code la Combie, malombie,a
attendreattendree second le sec,
et ce seet ce se moins fra moine
qu'on lequ'on leensait. pensait.
(brouhah(brouhahdes parta des p)
Car son Car sondversair adverst
homme, Rhomme, Rolfo Herodolfo e
homme d'homme d'faires daffaire.
Ses partSes partans fêisans fêns
rues de rues de n fief, son fie,
dont il dont il été le ma été l,
mais luimais luiil s'adr, il s'e
depuis sdepuis scuisine.a cuisi.
Son pro Son proamme : egramme r
avec la avec la rruptioncorrupte
de gouvede gouveement etrnementa
politicapoliticalerie. CilleriÇs
les médiles médi sociauxas socie
dans lesdans leserniers  dernieé
fulguranfulguran. C'est te. C'ed
BetancouBetancou a rejoirt a red
elle a melle a m fin àis fin àa.
Elle estElle estnthousia enthou.
INID BINGRID BANCOURT,ETANCOURTe
présidenprésidenelle coltielle 2
- Rodolf- RodolfHernandeo Herna,
c'est unc'est unype qui  type qr
fort, qufort, quva dénoni va dér
la corrula corruion fortption f,
qui va..qui va..qui ne v. qui ne
propositpropositns invraions in.
Mais il Mais il  dire véva diret
ce que lce que l gens pees gense
les chosles chos... commes... cs
doivent doivent tre prisêtre prn
et ce quet ce qul faut f'il fau.
C'est unC'est unon sens  bon se,
si vous si vous ulez, mavoulez,e
temps, ctemps, cst quelq'est qun
d'intelld'intellent.igent.
- Il n'a- Il n'aait aucu fait a,
sauf dansauf danles médis les m,
comme Jacomme Ja Bolsonair Bols,
ou Donalou DonalTrump, ad Trumps
on le coon le coare, maimpare, s
explosifexplosifGustavo . Gustai
fera pasfera pase caau de cadeaa
pas de jpas de jtice socustice ,
s'il y as'il y ae la cor de la .
"Mais o "Mais one comban ne cos
la corrula corruion avecption as
dans Tikdans Tikk."Tok."
Gustavo Gustavoet est Petro esx
routier routier  la polide la p,
sénateursénateurpourfend, pourf-
paramiliparamiliires, mataires,é
de Bogotde Bogot c'est sa, c'ese
tentativtentativà la pre à la p,
mais il mais il it peur fait pep
de Colomde Colomens.biens.
"Il fai "Il faipeur àt peur à't
colombiecolombie C'est un. C'esr
instruitinstruittrès in, très i,
bien prébien préré, maisparé, ms
en ont pen ont pr à caueur à caa
gestion gestion  la mairà la maa
et aussiet aussiarce qu' parce t
autoritaautoritae, allerire, ale
à la crà la crique."itique."
Fico, F Fico, Ferico Guederico,
s'attends'attendt à êait à êe ae
tour. Iltour. Ileprésent représe
colombiecolombiee, qui nnne, qua
jamais rjamais rn savoirien savr
d'un goud'un gournement verneme.
"Gustav "GustavPetro neo Petros
à la Coà la Combie."lombie."
"Il ser "Il serun dangea un da,
un dangeun dangepour la r pour ,
les libeles libeés, l'écrtés, l,
nos faminos famies et nolles et"
Les 24  Les 24 des voix% des vo
s'ajoutes'ajoutent probaront prt
aux 28 %aux 28 %e Rodolf de Rod,
ce qui lce qui l donneraui donne
au deuxiau deuxime tour.ème tou.
Autre p Autre pmière :remière e
vice-prévice-prédente sesidentee
afro-colafro-colbienne.ombienne.
Francia Francia rquez poMarquez;
Marelen Marelen stilloCastillo
pour Rodpour Rodfo Hernaolfo He.
La Colo La Coloie est embie esn
de fairede fairen pari h un par,
audacieuaudacieu car lesx, car x
finalistfinalist incarnees incae
désir dedésir dehangemen change.
Mais lesMais lesolombien Colomb,
vont faivont fai un sautre un ss
l'inconnl'inconnaprès u après 0s
de gouvede gouveements crnement,
discrédidiscrédis.tés.
Jean-Mi Jean-Miel Leprichel Le,
Radio-C Radio-Cada, Boganada, .